c'est ici dans sa chambre cessée par an
que sa carrière a commencé désormais
compositeur chevronnés Farouk qsm
peaufine une de ses dernières
productions surtout toutes les pistes
j'ai égalé les volumes etc j'ai éliminé
les fréquences sur par exemple les
cloches le piano etc en ce moment je
travaille beaucoup pour Jul et celle-ci
est d'ailleurs enfin d'ailleurs sera
proposé pour pour Julen la composition
démarre souvent par un tâtonnement au
clavier c'est avec cet instrument et un
simple ordinateur que Farouk débute pour
s'amuser sans notion de solfège en
reproduisant des mélodies à l'oreille
en 2020 durant le confinement il
investit dans du matériel professionnel
quelques temps plus tard il vend ses
premiers morceaux et parvient à toucher
Jul via les réseaux sociaux le rappeur
marseillais choisi certaines de ses
productions pour des albums à 23 ans
Farouk se voit récompenser pour sa
participation au projet à un disque d'or
c'est 50
000 ventes et le platine c'est c'est
100000 ventes pour moi en avoir un
c'était c'était un objectif mais aussi
un rêve là on a avoir quatre en recevoir
deux autres dans quelques temps enfin
c'est je ressens enfin je me laisse
emporter à tel point que début 2022 il
quitte un emploi dans la téléphonie pour
se consacrer uniquement à la musique et
sa musique Farouk qsm commence même à
l'exporter
qsm pour quartier Saint-Mard à
Romorantin là où enfant il fait la
connaissance de son ami hugur d'origine
turque comme Farouk hugur devient son
manager et entreprend de démarcher des
artistes Turcs j'ai étudié quatre ans en
Turquie aussi l'université
et du coup voilà j'avais plus de
j'ai plus d'expérience en Turquie
j'étais plus dans la vie active là-bas
on a pu
faire une session avec un avec un
artiste du coup qui s'appelle organiser
on a pu enregistrer des morceaux on a pu
travailler ensemble il y a des projets
qui sont en cours avec lui plusieurs
morceaux même ont été enregistrés avec
mes compositions et ça devrait sortir
dans l'année de Romorantin au bossfort
en passant par Marseille ou Paris
qsm rêve de diversifier ses
collaborations et composer de la musique
dans des styles variés